So
Ich bin wieder voll im Arsch Leute
Das wurde mir vorhin auch schon angeboten, dass ich das posten soll. Wusste gar nicht, dass das heute ist
Wie lange bin ich jetzt schon Partner? Vier Jahre oder so?
Irgendwie im Tränen
Ich kann jetzt instant einpennen
und bis morgen um 10 Uhr durchpennen.
Firefangs, Dankeschön. Massive Subscription.
Naja
Nichts besonderes. Einfach so
Ist halt manchmal mehr oder weniger anstrengend und zumal
Ich meine es ist ja immerhin schon fast Donnerstag. Da kann man ja auch mal müde sein
Döner habe ich am Dienstag gefordert
Döner Teller
Salat und Reis
Pog
Ist direkt bei mir um die Ecke. Wobei
Egal wo man wohnt, irgendein Dönerladen ist immer direkt um die Ecke
Icefreak, Dankeschön für den Sub
Kann man jetzt eigentlich immer Partyhead machen?
Kann man immer machen, okay
Das Gamtrain ist wieder am Start
Moment, Hype Lul. Das ist ja mein Fake-Account, der Hype Lul hat oder nicht hat
Ist ja egal, was der bekommt
Leute, ihr müsst mir irgendwas spannendes erzählen. Ich penne sonst ein. Ich habe übrigens, ich habe euch tatsächlich was zu erzählen
Wir werden heute einfach ein paar Sachen uns angucken und dann gehe ich in zwei Stunden pennen. Meinst man, du, ist heute echt Schluss
War bei euch irgendwas Spannendes heute oder war irgendwas Spannendes allgemein?
Lass mal kurz checken
Jo, juckt mich überhaupt nicht
Sky, Alter, wir hatten heutzutage noch ein Sky-Abo
Netflix will keine Leute mehr haben
Warum ist denn hier eigentlich, das ist doch auch nicht der News-Ticker
Daily-Übersicht. Hatte Heisen nicht mal eine ganz gute Daily-News-Übersicht? Irgendwie so um 18 Uhr oder so
Keine Ahnung, also ganz ehrlich, die Seite ist mittlerweile übelst zack
Ich gucke, ich gucke eigentlich hauptsächlich meine Reddit-Startseite oder Hacker-News, Hacker-News, beste
Hacker-News sieht einfach aus wie von 1995, aber taugt
Ich habe gerade meine Bewerbung für das Praktikum abgeschickt. Telekom IT Software Management, also die Telekom
Die Magenta Telekom
Und habe keine Bescheinigung, dass das Praktikum Pflicht ist. Schule ist zu und ich habe keine Bescheinigung
Also sie haben mir geantwortet, dass die Bescheinigung fehlt
Wie die Schule ist zu. Sind schon Sommerferien
Keck, wait
Na mal ganz davon abgesehen, was denken die sich denn, warum du ein Praktikum machen willst? Just for fun oder wie?
So, ich würde gerne ein Praktikum machen. Ja, ist das Pflicht? Ja, was meinst du denn, Alter?
Natürlich ist das Pflicht, sonst würde ich den Scheiß doch nicht machen
Ja gut, aber wahrscheinlich sagt irgendein interner Prozess bei denen, das muss so sein
Und selbst wenn es nicht Pflicht wäre, wo ist das Problem?
Umso größer der Laden, umso schwerfälliger und dümmer sind teilweise Abläufe
Ja, ja, aber wo wäre das Problem? Ist doch auch vollkommen okay
Sach halt, sollen das so bewerten, wie wenn du es nicht Pflicht machen müsstest
Was willst du machen? Du kannst jetzt ja keine... Ich meine, was du machen kannst, ist
Vielleicht, vielleicht... Was ist denn die nächst höhere Instanz von so einer... Instanz ist das falsche Wort... von so einer Schule, die
Keine Ahnung
Bildungstyp der Stadt oder so, keine Ahnung, wird sich doch irgendwas organisieren lassen
Der Sound ist wieder unausgewogen laut, wieder viel zu leise
Naja, wir müssen das halt sicherstellen, aber warum? Gibt doch auch Praktikanten, die das freiwillig machen. Wir hatten tatsächlich auch schon freie Praktikanten
Leute, ich hatte heute auf der Arbeit
Mein erstes, fragt mich nicht, was das genau steht, aber so ein
Förderungs- und Zukunftsgespräch mit meinem Chef
Das ist irgendwie nach drei Monaten Probezeit, dann ist das Pflicht
Und es sieht so aus
Als bleibe ich dem Laden noch ein bisschen länger erhalten
Weil die fanden alles ganz toll und alles gut
Ich glaube, ich habe sie wieder komplett zugeschwätzt
Ich habe mir eine Riesenliste mit Punkten gemacht, die ich mal ansprechen will und ich konnte irgendwie drei davon ansprechen
Normalerweise geht es, glaube ich, das eher um die Punkte, die in diesem offiziellen Formular drin stehen, aber
Die waren einfach nach 15 Minuten
Schon mehr oder weniger durch, da habe ich die nächsten 15 Minuten mit irgendwelchen Fragen vollgeschwätzt
Tja, ich bin trotzdem nicht alles losgeworden
Nee, aber es lief ganz gut, also ich bin jetzt anscheinend
Tatsächlich dort soweit angekommen, dass auch alles passt
Man muss sagen
Ein paar Sachen werde ich mich nie dran gewöhnen können, zum Beispiel wie super restriktiv beziehungsweise
Bürokratisch da alles ist
Aber gut, ich meine, hey
Letztendlich, sie bezahlen pünktlich und bezahlen nicht zu wenig
Da mache ich auch bürokratische Sachen, sollte sich halt keiner beschweren, wenn es länger dauert
Kann ich ja nichts für
Ja, genau
Ich würde sagen, die Mehrzahl der Programme unterstützt das nicht
Also, was damit gemeint ist, ist Single Sign-On, also sprich, dass du dich in Windows einloggst und Programme benutzt
Benutzt dann zum Beispiel die Windows Credentials
Oder sowas in der Richtung, ich würde sagen, die Mehrzahl der Programme kann das nicht
Pog
Wir müssen uns gleich von Fireships Weltkit erklären lassen
Was wir ja auch schon
Vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit
Bei uns wieder angeguckt haben
Was ist das denn?
Ein gefundenes Fressen für Cloud Gegner
Microsoft gehackt
Was ist denn da los wieder?
Hackermens unterwegs
Also, wenn Microsoft im großen Stil gehackt worden wäre, ich
Behaupte mal, das hätte ich mitbekommen
Das meine ich
Komm auch vielleicht nicht alles mit
Was? Ich hatte auch
Mit meiner Klasse eine Berufs-, oh nee, please, das habe ich auch gemacht, Chat, Chat
Ihr-, also, Frage an alle, die schon länger dabei sind, ich weiß, dass ihr das wisst, was ich euch jetzt fragen will
Was hat mir die Berufsorientierung empfohlen?
Was ich machen soll, obwohl ich explizit gesagt habe, ich würde gern was mit Computern machen
Was haben die-, arbeiten mit Holz, genau, die haben-, die haben gesagt, ich soll was mit Holz machen
Also, so-, also, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht-, hey, ich will jetzt mal nicht zu sehr über die herziehen
Vielleicht ist das ja auch alles besser geworden, gerade in Zeiten von Fachkräftemangel und allem
Vielleicht müssen sie sich ja auch mal die Flasche in meinem Arbeitsamt ein bisschen Mühe geben
Aber, ganz ehrlich, da kam zu kurz-, also, bei mir kam da nur Mist raus, bei dieser Berufsorientierung
Aber man muss es ja auch mal so verstehen
Das Arbeitsamt, das hat ja nicht den-, das hat ja nicht das Ziel, einen guten-, ja, eine gute-, gute Tätigkeit für dich zu finden, die zu dir passt
Sondern, die haben das Ziel, ihre offenen Stellen zu besetzen
Das heißt, die werden dir nie das empfehlen, was für dich am besten ist, sondern was für die Statistik am besten ist
Und wenn man das weiß, kann man sich auch direkt daraus ableiten, dass man einfach komplett abhängt
Kann man sich auch direkt daraus ableiten, dass man einfach komplett drauf scheißen kann, auf den Laden
So, also, was hast du denn geschrieben, oder so?
Äh, und das ist auch bei der Telekom
Ich habe einen guten Eindruck gemacht als Praktikant und die Mitarbeiter haben zu mir gesagt, dass sie sich wünschen, dass ich bei denen ein Praktikum machen soll
Also, quasi, was für eine Liste?
Meine Klasse ist sehr anstrengend, bin der einzige, der vernünftig ist
Ach, wenn es die Lehrer sagen, würde ich da nicht so viel drauf geben
Ich war auch jedes Mal in der Klasse
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch war, Leute
Egal, in welcher Klasse ich war, egal, in welcher Schule, haben die Lehrer immer getan, als wäre es die schlimmste Klasse
So nach dem Motto, oh, das ist aber die unruhigste Klasse, die ich seit langem gesehen habe
Oh, in dieser Klasse ist das ja
Das ist alles Bullshit, das ist bei jeder Klasse so
Dass die nervig sind
Ich meine, warum sollten die auch nicht nervig sein?
Das sind alles irgendwelche Halbstarken im Alter von, keine Ahnung, 14 bis 16
Ja, natürlich sind die abfucknervig
Die sind auch außerhalb von der Schule nervig, die sind immer nervig
Und davor auch schon, generell sind Kinder nervig
Also Menschen allgemein sind nervig, aber Kinder sind besonders nervig
Und Jugendliche ist die Krönung des Nervigseins
Wobei ich sagen muss, das stimmt nicht
Eine Sache habe ich gemerkt, so umso älter ich werde, umso mehr Leute gehen mir auf den Sack
Durch pures Existieren, die müssen gar nichts machen
Also mittlerweile bin ich so weit, wenn ich auf den Sack gehe
Kein Blödsinn, Leute, ist echt so
Früher konnte ich morgens nach Frankfurt fahren, das war mir eigentlich alles egal
Gut, früher bin ich auch früher gefahren, da haben die Leute zum größten Teil noch gepennt im Zug
Und da war nicht so viel los
Aber Leute, ich sage euch, die pure Existenz anderer Menschen in meiner unmittelbaren Umgebung fuckt mich mittlerweile ab
Es reicht schon, wenn die da sitzen und atmen, das nervt mich
Alles
Also mich nervt alles auf dem Weg zur Arbeit
Und zurück im Zug und drumherum und Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof
Und Leute, die die Augen nicht aufmachen können und gucken, was los ist
Es ist so schlimm
Was die Leute von sich geben, was die Leute für Geräusche machen, dass sie nicht gucken, geradeaus
Was die für eine Scheiße labern, wie dumm sie über die Straße laufen
Alles, mich fuckt alles ab
Die pure Existenz anderer Menschen in meiner Umgebung geht mir auf den Keks
Das ist jetzt im Alter noch schlimmer geworden
Also im Alter, ich bin jetzt 38, ja
Noch schlimmer geworden
Und ich bin froh, wenn mich einfach keiner auf den Keks geht
Jetzt weiß ich, wie das für meinen Opa war, ja, mit 80
Doppelt so schlimm war das Ganze wahrscheinlich
Das ist echt ätzend
Ich meine, es ist nicht so, als würde ich es nicht aushalten oder so
Aber es nervt mich einfach total vieles
Genau, das haben sie gesagt
Bei dir hat die Berufsorientierung Diätassistent gesagt
Funfact, die Lehrer haben auch zu mir gesagt, ich soll was mit Holz machen, aber die Telekom will mich
Ich meine, ohne Scheiß, wenn man da irgendwie Bock drauf hat
Also, handwerkstechnisch kann man sicherlich auch gut Kohle machen
Aber, du willst wahrscheinlich eher was mit Computer machen
Wo seht ihr so als größtes Problem in Projekten?
Ich sehe, dass ein Zeitmeinerspend quasi nicht mehr existiert bei euch
Auch so, das kommt immer auf das Projekt an
Ich finde, gerade wenn die Zeit knapp ist
Beziehungsweise, wenn die Kacke ein bisschen am Dampfen ist
Dann entscheidet sich, ob vieles, was im Vorfeld erzählt wird, nur leeres Gelaber ist
Oder wirklich auch gemacht wird
Also, wenn man dann immer sagt, so nach dem Motto, Stabilität und Blablabla ist uns das Wichtigste
Und das und das ist hier superwichtig und das ist superwichtig
Aber wenn die Zeit knapp wird und dann alles über Bord geschmissen wird
Dann weiß man, okay, so wirklich drauf geben, wenn was gesagt wird, kann man nicht
Zeitmanagement kommt halt immer ein bisschen drauf an
Wer das macht und was da für Interessen verfolgt
Es gibt genug Projektmanager, die möchten einfach gut dastehen
Und kommunizieren Verzögerungen nicht
Weil das für sie schlecht aussieht
Die denken sich, hey, lieber böses Erwachen und dann muss man es verschieben
Anstatt, dass ich im Vorfeld immer regelmäßig sage, dass man hinten dran ist
Also, ja, das scheitert oftmals tatsächlich der unfähigen Projektmanagern
Welche Tastatur und Maus hast du auf der Arbeit? Leiste Switches wegen Büro?
Also, ich habe eine Ducky One Skyline auf der Arbeit
Allerdings hier so eine in der Richtung mit Num Block
Ah, die gibt es keine mehr, hier so, so sieht die aus, genau
Aber ich habe eine Full-Size Enter-Taste, nicht dieses hässliche Ding, alter
Was ist das für ein Schrott? Will ich nicht
Full-Size, Full-Size Enter-Taste, hier so wie die da, so wie die aussieht
Bloß, dass ich ein paar andere Farbigkeiten
Also, ich habe eine Ducky One Skyline auf der Arbeit, sieht mehr oder weniger genauso aus wie die
Mit, ich glaube, Cherry Brown Switches sind das
Die sind nicht super leise
Aber ich habe unter die Tasten, wo ich besonders hart immer drauf schlage
Beispielsweise auf die Num Block Enter-Taste und so, also eine Leertaste
Da habe ich so kleine Silikonringe drunter gemacht, dass es den Leuten nicht zu sehr auf den Keks geht
So, und Maus, Maus habe ich eine Logitech G502
Das ist die ganz alte, die mir mal jemand auf der Gamescom, die mir mal einer von Logitech auf der Gamescom in die Hand gedrückt hat
Als wir bei denen am Stand einen Termin hatten
Wir sind, wir sind, die haben uns ihre, ihre, ihre Hardware gezeigt und sonst was
Und da wollten wir gehen und da hat er gemeint, ach Jungs, komm hier, nehmt einfach mit
War richtig random, ja
Ich meine, wir haben uns da gut verstanden, ich fand auch das eigentlich alles ganz, ganz interessant
Es war jetzt nichts dabei, wo ich gesagt habe, oh ja, da muss ich demnächst für euch 5 Sellout-Videos machen
Ne, nicht kabellos
Da sind wir rausgegangen
Und da hat er so gemeint, einfach das, was er uns da gezeigt hat
Das war also eine G502
Ach komm Jungs, wisst ihr was, nehmt einfach mit
Davon habe ich noch die G502, also nicht die Hero, sondern es war noch G502
Oh, Protoyscore hieß das Ding noch
Das Ding, ja
Und ungrünstiger Winkel, da sieht die Maus viel fetter aus, als sie ist
Ja, die zwei Kombinationen habe ich fürs Büro
G502 und Duckymon Skyline
Tastatur ist ein bisschen laut
Aber
Wenn man nicht so super heftig auf die Tasten schlägt
Und bei manchen Tasten Silikonring drunter macht, vollkommen in Ordnung
Kann ich übrigens auch empfehlen, ich mag die
Wenn man, wohlgemerkt, wenn man
Tastaturen mag mit Numpad und sowas
Ich glaube, die gibt es auch kürzer, ich glaube, die gibt es sogar ohne
Ohne Pfeiltasten
Aber ich mag Fullsize-Tastatur
Habe ich ja auch
Da kommt mir nichts anderes in die Tüte
Also die kann ich prinzipiell empfehlen, die Tastatur
Aber mit dem normalen Layout, nicht mit diesem Enter-Knopf da
Die ist gut
Gibt allerdings tausend andere ganz gute mechanische Tastaturen mittlerweile
Braucht die irgendeine Software?
Nein
Die hat noch nicht mal eine Software
Du kannst Makros machen
Mit der Tastatur, die hat einen eingebauten Microcontroller
Für Makros
Das ist aber mega abartig zu bedienen
Die hat unten so ein paar Switches
Da kannst du Makros, Makro enablen und Makro aufzeichnen
Das ist dann in der Tastatur alles gespeichert
Benutze ich nicht, weiß ich aber, dass es das hat
Ja, so werde ich auch mal irgendwann
Wobei ich sagen muss, bei mir ist es anders
Bei mir ist es anders
Also alte, verbitterte Leute sind für mich die Leute, die erzählen so
Früher war das alles viel besser
Und so früher im Osten, so als die Mauer noch da war
Da herrschte noch Ordnung
Das sind für mich so alte, verbitterte Leute
Und bevor es Computer gab, da war die Welt noch viel besser
Ich kann einfach andere Leute nicht ab
Und ich merke das immer mehr
Umso älter ich werde
Besonders fremde Leute
Beispielsweise mit den Leuten auf der Arbeit
Habe ich überhaupt keine Schmerzen
Die kenne ich mittlerweile auch schon ein bisschen besser
Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass da 50 Leute im Büro sitzen würden
Und außerdem sind die auch alle ein bisschen zurückhaltender
Also das passt schon
Aber ansonsten, so in der Öffentlichkeit und generell
Mich fucken Leute so ab
Ich könnte mich permanent über alles, was ich sehe, was Leute machen
Irgendwie aufregen
Leute, die dich anhusten und nicht die Hand vor den Mund halten können
Leute, die absichtlich aus der Tür gehen und nicht in die Richtung gucken, wo die Leute herkommen
Die sich eben zu breit machen
Die die ganze Zeit doof rumhusten müssen
Alles mich fuckt das so ab
Also die Anwesenheit von Menschen geht mir auf den Keks mittlerweile
Ich sage nicht, dass die Welt früher besser war
Aber die Leute gehen mir auf den Sack
Und die Leute wären mir auch vor 50 Jahren auf den Sack gegangen, wenn ich da der Gleiche gewesen wäre
Ja, Leute im Zug, die direkt einsteigen und dich nicht aussteigen
Genau so Sachen, das geht mir
Früher hat mich das eigentlich, das hat mich zwar genervt
Aber da habe ich mir immer gedacht so
Dumme, dumme Leute
Aber heute regt mich das so richtig auf
Das regt mich so
Ich werde dann teilweise übelst angepisst
Also übelst innerlich aggressiv, wenn ich sowas merke
Letztens mal, das darfst eigentlich keinem erzählen
Eines der letzten Male, wo ich zum Südbahnhof gefahren bin
Ich muss jetzt erzählen, dass ich nicht wieder komplette Spaß darüber bekomme
Aber ich muss jetzt überlegen, in welcher Reihenfolge das Ganze
Ja, genau, ich weiß es wieder
Also, passt auf
Okay, ich zeige euch ein Bild
Südbahnhof-Wahnsteig
Gibt es da nicht mal ein ordentliches Bild vom Südbahnhof?
Alter, da kommen 100.000 Leute vorbei, warum gibt es da kein ordentliches
Gleis, keine Ahnung, 6 oder so
Was?
Ja, das ist Überschwemmung
Also, es gibt anscheinend im Internet kein ordentliches Bild vom Frankfurter Südbahnhof
Wo man die Treppe und das Gleis in einem sieht
Achso, Frankfurt wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt
Ja, ich bin ja auch blöd
Hier, wunderbar, exzellent, hier ist perfekt
Hier ist, genau dieses Bild habe ich gebraucht
Genau dieses Bild habe ich gebraucht
Also, mein Zug hält hier
So
Ich steige ungefähr aus dem Zug aus auf der Höhe von hier
Sieht man nicht im Bild, so
Ich, ich
Ich laufe hier, ach guck mal
Gibt sogar Hi-Res, Hi-Res Bild, wenn man es ein bisschen laden lässt
Einfach nur alarm
Es
Fuck, mit der Seite los
Na gut
Zumindest, ich laufe hier
Und morgens ist es ja
Das ist übrigens auch eine Sache, die mich übelst aufregt
Leute, die die linke Hälfte der Rolltreppe blockieren und stehen bleiben
Morgens, wo sich da irgendwie 5000 Leute die, die Rolltreppe runter, runter schlängeln
Ja
Normalerweise gibt es ein ungeschriebenes Gesetz auf den Rolltreppen
Hier im Frankfurter Südbahnhof
Chat, wer weiß es
Wie steht man auf der Rolltreppe, wahrscheinlich nicht am Südbahnhof
Sondern, sondern generell auf Rolltreppen in Bahnhöfen
Wie, wie steht man?
Links gehen, rechts stehen, richtig
Genau, so, so ist das normalerweise
Das kann auch jeder
Und jeder, der es nicht kann, sieht
Und das regt mich auch immer auf
Wenn dann Leute
Links stehen
Und, und grundlos einfach links stehen und sich nicht bewegen
So mitten auf der Treppe
Und, und, und alle, alles staut sich dahinter, weil die Depthness nicht checken
Zumindest, eigentlich, eigentlich die Story, die ich erzählen wollte
So, ich bin hier ausgestiegen und da bildet sich halt so eine kleine, kleine Schlange, ja
Und dann geht es hier so die Rolltreppe, geht es dann die Rolltreppe runter, so
Und es gibt manchmal Leute, die steigen aus dem Zug aus
Also die Schlange vor der, vor der Rolltreppe bildet sich dann hier so ungefähr
Dass die Leute, die, die gliedern sich dann so alle ein, dass sie da runter kommen
So, und dann gibt es manchmal Leute, die steigen aus dem Zug aus
Laufen bis ganz am Anfang von der Rolltreppe
Und wollen sich dann reinquetschen von der Seite
Wisst ihr, die Leute haben sich vorher schon sortiert
Stehen halt zehn Leute hintereinander, es geht langsam runter, alles okay
Und dann hast du Leute, die rennen da vorbei, flitzen da vorbei und wollen sich da rein, reindrängeln von der Seite, ja
Und ich hab's schon gesehen
Ich hab mich da halt einsortiert, lauf da runter
Und ich hab den Typ, ich hab's schon gesehen
Ich hab's schon gesehen aus dem Augenwinkel, dass da einer kommt, ja
Ich, ich, ich hab's schon, ich hab's, ich hab's schon gesehen
Weil wisst ihr, woran man die Leute erkennt?
Also nicht nur, dass sie schnell vorbeilaufen
Dass sie absichtlich nicht in die Richtung gucken, wo Leute stehen
Die gucken so nach dem Motto in die andere Richtung
Ihr seht mich ja nicht und ich geh da jetzt rein
Und dann steht der Typ neben mir und will halt neben mir rein
Und da hab ich ihm einen leichten Ellenbogen in, in, im Bauch gehauen
Nicht fest, nicht Körperverletzung fest
Ich hab einfach, der Typ ist da, der Typ ist da, der Typ ist da, der Typ ist da
Ich hab einfach, der Typ ist da, der ist da zackig rein
Der ist da zackig rein
Ich hab einfach den Ellenbogen in seine Richtung gemacht
Da ist er halt reingelaufen, da hat er gemacht
Hat irgendwie versucht anzufangen zu meckern
Aber da war ich schon weg
Und ich hab gesagt, Alter, dir, dir geschieht's recht
Dir geschieht's recht
Musst du aufpassen, wenn du Richtung, Richtung kommst im, ja, ey, nee
Das geht ja nicht
Also an der, an der Stelle geht's ja nicht
Der ist ja schon alles weiter und, und 500 Leute an dem vorbei
Aber ganz ehrlich, sowas regt mich immer richtig auf
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt stellt euch, jetzt, ich will jetzt nicht falsch verstanden werden
Ich hab jetzt nicht voll ausgerollt dem, dem Ellenbogen in den Magen gerammt
Dass er, dass er kotzend aufs Gleis gefallen ist oder so, ja
Nicht, nicht, nicht falsch verstehen
Ich hab, ich hab den Ellenbogen halt so zur Seite schon gemacht
Weil ich den Typ gesehen hab, wie der reinflitzen will
Und als er dann gegen den Ellenbogen gerannt ist
Hab ich halt noch so ein bisschen zurück, zurückgestimmt, so zurückgeschoben
So, fertig
Die Leute regen mich auf
Wie gesagt, mittlerweile bin ich soweit, dass die
Weil ich hier gelandet bin
Mittlerweile bin ich soweit, dass die pure Existenz anderer Menschen in meinem Umfeld mich nervt
Was war übrigens gerade hier
So, so viel, so viel zum Assi, Assi Bahnhof in, in Frankfurt
Und was auch geil ist
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr Leute, die ich auch, die ich auch mega geil finde morgens am Bahnhof
Und zwar
Also was ihr wissen müsst, was man hier jetzt nicht sieht
Was man hier nicht sieht
Hier sind Rolltreppen
In der Regel ist es so, dass die Leute hier raufkommen und hier runterfahren
Weil, naja, die Rolltreppen halt
Gehen halt in die Richtung
Ja, manchmal hast du welche, die rennen da noch
Das ist aber gar nicht das Problem
Was mich nervt ist
Gegenüber, das müsst ihr wissen, hier gegenüber ist eine normale Treppe
Also so eine Treppe mit Stufen
Und, und, und irgendwo hinten ist glaube ich sogar noch ein
Oder irgendwo auf dem Gleis ist glaube ich sogar noch ein Fahrstuhl
Für, für Gehbehinderte
Ist eigentlich alles ganz gut gemacht am Südbahnhof
Aber hier drüben ist eine Treppe
So, und dann hast du Leute, die fahren mit dem Fahrrad im Zug
Und ich weiß nicht, also ich hab's persönlich noch nicht probiert
Aber ich kann euch sagen
Wenn da irgendwie 8000 Leute morgens die Rolltreppe runter
Wir schauen gleich das Fireship wieder
Wenn da 8000 Leute morgen, die morgens die Rolltreppe runter wollen
Und dann Leute mit dem Fahrrad quasi auf der Schulter da angerückt kommen
Ohne links und rechts zu gucken
Das Fahrrad hat ja auch ein bisschen
Bisschen größeren Winkel, den das, den das Ganze einnimmt, ja
Und die dann meinen, sie müssen auch in die Rolltreppe reinspringen
Anstatt die Treppe runter zu gehen
Kann ich verstehen
Ich laufe übrigens mittlerweile lieber die Treppe, muss ich sagen
Anstatt die, anstatt die Rolltreppe
Ich steige einfach ein bisschen weiter hinten ein und laufe die Treppe
Treppe ist deutlich entspannter
Hat man mehr Platz, weniger Gerangel und so
Rolltreppe ist eigentlich
Also, die 5-Fet-Leute am Südbahnhof, die laufen alle Treppe
Aber manchmal steige ich halt von der Seite aus
Und ich will da nicht komplett hier rumlaufen und runter
Aber wenn ich, also wenn ich kann
Und der Zug halt auch so hält
Weil manchmal fährt der auch viel weiter hinter
Dann steige ich da hinten aus und fahre
Äh, fahre nicht mit der Rolltreppe, sondern laufe die Treppe runter
Naja, egal
So viel zum Frankfurter Südbahnhof
Übrigens, Projekt
Wo wir es gerade hatten hier
Projektplanung auf der Arbeit
Gestern, jetzt, jetzt ungelogen
Das passt wirklich gut zu diesem Thema
Was ihr gerade hier hattet mit Projekt- und Zeitmanagement
Also
Gestern hatten wir ein Projekt-Status-Meeting auf der Arbeit
Da muss ich nur dabei hocken und interessiert gucken
Ich muss da nicht wirklich irgendwas machen
Da stellen Projektleiter aus unterschiedlichen Teilbereichen
So ihr Progress beziehungsweise vor, ob es Verspätungen gibt
Und gestern war noch Status in diesem Meeting
Alles grün
Bis auf ein paar Kleinigkeiten
Da ist man, da hat man ein bisschen Verzögerung
Die sind auf orange
Aber ansonsten alles gut, wir gehen in zwei Monaten live
So
Und heute
Das muss man sich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen
Ein Tag später
Äh, hieß es heute
Auf dem, auf dem
Nachmittags-Meeting
Ach, übrigens, also
Das live gehen können wir nicht einhalten
Das müssen wir wahrscheinlich verschieben
Wir wissen noch nicht wohin
Haben wir nicht gestern noch
Status-Meeting, wo alles grün war
Also es muss doch einen Unterschied geben von
Alles grün zu, wir müssen den Live-Gang verschieben
Da muss es doch so Zwischenschritte geben
So nach dem Motto, oh Leute, langsam wird es knapp
Achtung, bald ist es nicht mal zu halten
Oh, knapp
Das wird ganz eng und wir können es nicht
Das kann doch nicht sein, heute ist alles grün
Äh, gestern ist alles grün
Und heute, aber wir schaffen das nicht, da live zu gehen
Ich kann euch auch sagen, woran es liegt
Es liegt daran
Dass ein Dienstleister, der eine Software liefern soll
Nicht in der Lage ist, die Software rechtzeitig zu liefern
Aber
Also man könnte mal sagen, ja gut
Äh, äußere Umstände, das kann ja das Projektmanagement nicht wissen
Aber
Genau für sowas ist das Projektmanagement da
Unter anderem, um auch alternative Zeitpläne parat zu haben
Und vor allem
Ist dieser Hersteller bekannt dafür
Und hat es in der Vergangenheit
Der Hersteller hat in der Vergangenheit noch
Keinen einen Termin eingehalten
Also warum es grün ist
Und rein auf dem Versprechen des Herstellers basiert
Obwohl der Hersteller sich in der Vergangenheit
Nie an die Termine gehalten hat
Ist mir auch ein Rätsel
Da weiß ich auch manchmal nicht, was da Projektmanagementtechnisch läuft
Aber
Mir ist es recht, ich finde es sogar gut, dass es verzögert wird
Weil da können wir die Sachen besonders ordentlich machen
Ohne dass wir dran schuld wären
Dass es verschoben werden muss
Ich finde das gut
Aber
Das ist lustig
Gestern noch den Termin, alles grün, alles toll
Heute, ach übrigens, wir müssen es verschieben
Ich verzweifle an nichts
Wo es mit Forever auf einer NVIDIA-Kiste
Nein, haben wir nicht ausprobiert
Die Musikplaylist ist sehr unausgewogen laut
Immer sagen, way ahead of schedule
Ja, das hat man bei DICE
Gut, bei DICE hat es ja auch irgendwo
Funktioniert
Sie haben es ja released
Zum Zeitpunkt, wo sie es releasen sollten
Das war halt kaputt
Das ist dann halt, wie es läuft
Man kann es auch einfach kaputt releasen
Und dann sagen, ah ja, wir patchen das alles gut
Was sie bis heute nicht geschafft haben
Es ist jetzt in einem Zustand, wo man sich überlegen könnte
Es vielleicht mal zu releasen
Hast du schon gesehen, was das USB-Konsortium
Mit der USB-Namens-Gemo macht?
Nein, das gucke ich mir gleich an
Ich will nicht so weit hinten dran sein mit dem Chat
Gucken wir uns gleich an
Stellt dir der Arbeitgeber die Homeoffice-Ausstattung
Also, die würden
Teilweise Sachen stellen
Ich glaube, die stellen dir sogar komplett
Ich glaube, du kannst Homeoffice
Ich glaube, du kannst einen kompletten Homeoffice-Arbeitsplatz beantragen
Mit bis zu zwei Monitoren
Dockingstation und Zeug
Habe ich aber nicht
Wozu?
Ich habe meine zwei Monitore
Ich habe hier meinen Schreibtisch, Tastatur, Maus
Das Einzige, was ich benutze, ist das Laptop von der Arbeit
Brauche ich nicht
Aber würden sie?
Ja, das
Das sollte es aber nicht sein
Wenn ich 4 GB auf einem anderen Laufwerk kopiere
Geht es halt eine bestimmte Zeit
Bei mir lässt sich jeder Projektbeteiligte
in einer Minute erledigen
Das dauert so und so lang
Und wenn sie sich beschweren wollen
Und damit Probleme haben
Sollen sie halt zu deinem Chef und sich da beschweren
Manchmal macht es gar keinen Sinn
Überhaupt mit den Leuten zu diskutieren
Also, wenn das so übliche Verdächtige
Ich würde nicht von Anfang an
Also, nicht falsch verstehen
Ich würde nicht von Anfang an auf Konfrontationskurs gehen
Und gleich sagen, ihr könnt mich mal
Sondern, wenn das wiederholt die gleichen Leute sind
Die mit so einem Zeug um die Ecke kommen
Auch noch, wenn das irgendwelche Leute sind
Die sich genau um die Koordination von sowas kümmern sollen
Dann bleibt dir ja manchmal nichts anderes übrig
Kann sagen, okay, das dauert jetzt 30 Minuten
Oder das sind Sachen, die brauche ich einen Tag für
Und wenn die sagen, oh nee, das geht nicht
Dann halt nicht
Gehe zu meinem Chef, wenn es dich stört
Aber kann man nichts dran ändern
Ich meine, das dauert halt so lang
Gibt es ja jemanden mit Vernunft, der mich davon abhalten kann
Neuen PC zu kaufen
Also, mich darfst du da nicht fragen
Mein neuer PC ist auch kompletter Schwachsinn gewesen
Ich habe den Rest von den Komponenten zum damaligen Kaufzeitpunkt
Und eigentlich hätte es mein Alter theoretisch
Im Zweifelsfall auch ein halbes Jahr
Oder maximal ein Jahr noch getan
Nö, es ist eigentlich nie verkehrt
Zu einem neuen PC
Außerdem hast du Schweizer Money
Und Easy Money, Easy Life
Und hast eh genug Geld für einen PC
Ein besserer Rechner vom Wubblers
Das ist mittlerweile sogar möglich
Bei meinem Rechner
Ist er immerhin jetzt auch schon Dreivierteljahr alt
Naja, nicht ganz
Aber doch, fast
Ne, wie gesagt
Die Tastatur braucht keine Extrasoftware
Aber du kannst Makros machen
Mit so einem eingebauten Switch
Da ist unten so ein Dipswitch dran
Und da kannst du Makroaufnahme starten, beenden und abrufen
Ganz merkwürdig benutze ich nicht
Low-Profile Keyboards mag ich überhaupt nicht
Ist das das mit den bunten Tastaturen?
Ja, ne
Doch, ja genau
Diese bunten Tastaturen
Ja, die kenne ich
Hat mich aber persönlich nicht so angesprochen
Hast du ein 7.950x?
Nein, habe ich nicht
Ich habe noch ein 13.900k
Aber rein für Games
Sind glaube ich die allerneuesten AMD Dinger
Sogar noch ein Ticken besser
Zumindest in manchen Games
Manchen Benchmarks
Es war früher viel schlechter
Man wird sich immer einzelne Dinge rauspicken können
So wo man sagen könnte
Oh, das war früher aber viel besser
Aber insgesamt bin ich immer noch der Meinung
Auch wenn überall rumgegangen ist
Und man immer noch so zugeheult wird
Wenn man sich mal Twitter und Social Media anguckt
Die tun ja so als wäre die Welt noch nie so schlimm gewesen
Wie heute
Aber ist die Welt eigentlich
Wenn man es mal genau nimmt
Zumindest was persönliche Entfaltung angeht
Und gerade auch bei uns hier
Lebensstandard und was es alles für Möglichkeiten gibt
Das Beste was es hier gegeben hat
Aber so dieses super
Wir sehen alles schwarz
Und jeder denkt er ist super unterdrückt
Wobei es noch nie so gut war in der Richtung
Ich sage nicht, dass es keine Probleme gibt
Wo man sich Gedanken drüber machen kann
Oder auch keine Probleme gibt
Wo man noch was ändern muss
Aber insgesamt ist das eigentlich wunderbar
Die aktuelle Zeit
Ich weiß auch nicht warum alle hier
Gerade was Twitter angeht
So den Untergang daher beireden immer
Geht mir genauso
Ja ich glaube es geht vielen
Leute im Zug
Die direkt einsteigen und dich nicht aussteigen lassen
Jo
Ich hatte mal einen
Der in Hanau war das am Hauptbahnhof
Muss man sich echt mal vorstellen
Beim aussteigen
Hast du ja in so einem Zug
Meistens Leute die von links kommen
Zur Tür
Leute die von rechts kommen
Und Leute die von
Halbrechts kommen
Bei so Doppeldeckerzügen
Also von der linken Seite kommen die Leute
Die aus dem Nachbarwagon kommen
Von ganz rechts kommen die Leute
Die von oben runter kommen
Und von ja so
Mitte
Mitte auf der rechten Seite kommen die
Die von unten raus kommen
So und ich hatte in Hanau mal einen
Da ist die Tür aufgegangen
Und der ist
Wisst ihr noch wie man so Kopfsprungen macht
Ins Schwimmbad
Der hat die Arme so nach vorne gemacht
Wie wenn er so beim Brustschwimmen
Gerade ausholen will
Und ist dann zwischen zwei Schlangen
Halb gedeift
Der hat die Arme nach vorne gemacht
Und ist zwischen die zwei Schlangen
Aber es war gut
Die Leute sind einfach weitergelaufen
Und irgendwie 20 Sekunden später
Stand er irritiert auf dem Bahnsteig
Einfach ganz ganz merkwürdig
Was auch
Was auch witzig war
Wo wir gerade bei Bahnstorys sind
Ich bin auf der
Vorletzten Arbeit
Bin ich manchmal mit einem heimgefahren
Von
Aus meinem Team
Ihr müsst wissen der hatte zwar in der IT gearbeitet
Der war aber früher
Weiß gar nicht wie man das nennt
Nicht Bauarbeiter
Aber der hat
So Handwerkliches angemacht
Es war schon ein ziemliches Tier der Kerl
Und das war in Frankfurt
Das war in Frankfurt auch mal so
Das
Das war mal ein mit dem Fahrrad
Der über den Fuß
Also einsteigen
Da kam ein Typ mit dem Fahrrad
Ist ihn über den Fuß gerollt
Da hat er einfach
Den Typ gegriffen
Ist 2 Stücke zurück gegangen
Hat ihn wieder auf den Bahnsteig gestellt
So wie wenn du irgendeinen Müllsack rausstellst
Aber der Typ der ist auch irgendwie
1,95 oder so
Und hat übelst Kraft
Der ist mit dem Fahrrad über den Fuß gerollt
Hat den Typ einfach geschnappt
So 2 Meter nach links gestellt
Neben am Zug und ist eingestiegen
Der kann sich das trauen
Ansonsten Frankfurt Bahnhof
Weiß man nicht so genau
Bahnhof ist echt immer so ein Ding
Wo man sich über andere Leute aufregt
Ja das gibt es
Egal genug
Ich wollte gerade auch was dazu erzählen
Aber genug Zugsachen
Das kann hier Frankfurt
Aber das war der Südbahnhof
Nicht der Hauptbahnhof
Am Hauptbahnhof ist das wahrscheinlich
Also Nothalt auf der Rolltreppe habe ich noch nie erlebt
Nothalt auf der Rolltreppe
Ist aber gut dass es sowas gibt
Es gab doch mal vor zig Jahren
So ein Video
Wo in China oder so
In irgendeinem asiatischen Land
So eine Platte weggeflogen ist
Von der Rolltreppe
Und eine Frau quasi in das Getriebe von der Rolltreppe gefallen ist
Google please Leute Leute Leute
Ich hätte es nicht erzählen sollen
Tut mir einen Gefallen Google nicht danach
Ich weiß manche googlen jetzt
Aber ich glaube ihr wollt das nicht sehen
Google nicht danach
Ich sage auch nicht weiter
Unüberlegtes Zeug was ich erzähle
Ich will nicht dass die Leute hier nicht richtig schlafen können
Wir schauen das Feierstück Video gleich
Anonyme Umfrage
Ja das ist auch lustig
Das ist auch lustig
Ihr wisst ja ich arbeite Montags nicht
Das heißt ich war Dienstag den ersten Tag der Woche da
Dienstag also gestern
War ungelogen Meeting
Durchgängig von 9.30 bis 16 Uhr
Mit einer halben Stunde Pause Zeit für Mittagessen
Und das ist nicht übertrieben
Das ist wirklich exakt
So wie ich euch das jetzt erzählt habe
Im Kalender
Also nicht dieses
Ich habe den ganzen Tag gemietet
Aber im Prinzip waren es nur drei Meetings
Und jeweils 45 bis 1,5 Stunden Pause dazwischen
Ne ne
Es war wirklich durchgängig
Aneinander Termine bis außer 30 Minuten
Zu Mittagessen
So und heute morgen hatten wir Daily
Und da meint auch einer
Ja ich übergebe jetzt mal an Max
Gibt keinen neuen Status
Gestern war der erste Tag der Woche
Wir haben den ganzen Tag gemietet
Und jetzt ist es 9.30 Uhr
Hat sich doch nichts getan
Muss man aber sagen
Die sind wenigstens so drauf
Aber ich finde es schon geil
Was will man denn bitte schon dafür
Einen Status berichten können
Aber ist ja gut
Das gehört ja zu solchen agilen Arbeitsweisen
Dass jeder mal dran kommt was er an kann
An das Trinken erinnern gute Idee
Hast du schon gesehen was das USB Konsortium
Mit der USB 4 nach
Oh ich ahne Schlimmes
Ich ahne Schlimmes
USB 4 Version 2.0
Oh nein
Oh
Was ist mit denen los
Die machen doch
Die machen doch einen Wettbewerb oder
Die
Die machen doch ernsthaft einen Wettbewerb
Wie man
Also wer hat noch eine Idee
Wie man das undurchsichtiger
Und noch weniger logisch machen könnte
Vorherige Bezeichnung
Aber das
Das war doch die ganze Zeit schon so
Ach das haben die umbenannt
Das haben die umbenannt
Die haben USB 3.2
Oh das ist so ein Abfuck
Alter ich hasse den USB Standard
Für solche Dinger
USB 3.2
Gen 2x2
Das ist doch vollkommen okay
Dass der Krempel so heißt
Der kam halt raus
Als USB 3.2
Ich meine allein schon die ursprüngliche Namensgebung
USB 3.2
Gen 2x2
Ist einfach schon komplett gehirnverbrannt
Übrigens Chat wer weiß
Auf was sich das 2x2 bezieht
Also das mal 2
Nicht das 2x2
Das zweite Generation 2
Das mal 2
PCI Express Lines
Ja fast sowas in der Richtung
Nee Datenkabel
Also Datenleitungen da drinne
Ja
Also als würde das irgendeinen Endkunde interessieren
Wie viele Datenleitungen da drinne sind
Dass den interessiert 20 Gigabit
40 Gigabit oder sonst was in der Richtung
Aber ich meine
Ich glaube es wird mal wieder Zeit
Für Flamen über USB Standard Videos
USB 4.0 Gen 2x2
Nein
Es ist nicht USB 4.0 Gen 2x2
Es ist fucking USB 3.2
Gen 2x2
Damit kam es raus
Du kannst nicht Sachen
Retroaktiv umbenennen
So funktionieren Versionsnummer nicht
Ich kann nicht
Ich kann jetzt nicht auch eine Software rausbringen
Ja oder ich bring jetzt
Ich bring jetzt jahrelang eine Software raus
Und sag ah das ist Versionsnummer
Das ist Version 1
Das ist 1.5
Das ist 1.6, 1.7
Und jetzt benenne ich einfach
Die letzte Version die ich releast habe
1.7
Um in 5.3
So funktioniert das mit Versionen nicht
Wenn ich eine neue Version mache
Dann kann ich die quasi nennen
Wenn ich will
Wenn es natürlich auch sinnvoll ist
Das irgendwie konsistent zu dem alten zu benennen
Aber ich kann nicht Retroaktiv Versionen umbenennen
Das ergibt keinen Sinn
Es sind Versionsnummern dafür
Nicht das richtige
Und man sieht bei WiFi
Ja das es ganz gut funktioniert
Die Dinger heißen jetzt WiFi 4
WiFi 5, WiFi 6
Ok WiFi 6E haben wir glaube ich jetzt auch
Aber immerhin
Man blickt es noch halbwegs
Oh das ist so dumm
Und um die ganze Sache jetzt noch perfekt zu machen
Machen sie jetzt so halbe halbe
Gen 3x2 USB 4 Version 1
Ok man muss ja der Fairness halber sagen
USB 4 Version 1
USB 4 Version 2
Ist eigentlich schon mal
Eine etwas bessere Benamung
Immerhin
Ist es ein bisschen kürzer und knapper
Aber ganz im Ernst
Ich weiß nicht ob denen das vielleicht noch jemand erklären muss
Aber Versionsnummern
Werden nicht dadurch besser
Dass Version dabei steht
Also eine Versionsnummer
Wie USB 4.0
Und USB 4.1
Da checkt die Jungs
4.1
Da checkt jeder
Dass 4.1
Die Generation nach
Oder die Updated Version
Von 4.0 ist
Dafür sind Versionsnummern eigentlich da
Version 2.0
Da rein zu schreiben
Ist total doppelt gemoppelt
Man könnte es einfach USB 4.1
Oder meinetwegen USB 4.2
Wenn man es unbedingt 2 nennen will
Da rein schreiben
Aber so
Ich bin auch nur ein Weird Champ
Was sie da abziehen
Ist das so
Kannst du einen elektrisch schön verstellbaren Tisch empfehlen?
Ich habe einen
Aber den würde ich nicht unbedingt empfehlen
Du kannst einen RefLink von mir verwenden
Wo wir gerade dabei sind
Sekunde
Habe ich nicht einen Sellout gemacht
Für einen Tisch
Irgendwann im letzten Jahr
Da
Matchmasters
Ne
Ich habe einen Tisch Sellout gemacht
Das war Genshin Impact
Hallo Leute hier ist der Max
Wo habe ich den Tisch Sellout gemacht
Ich weiß das gar nicht mehr
Ich blicke den mal durch
Gigabit Glasfaser
Hier da
Flexi
Aber ob die Dinger jetzt
Richtig gut sind
Also der hier ist zumindest
Ganz gut brauchbar
Aber ob das für dich der richtige
Der richtige
Ist
Keine Ahnung
Kannst du Sellout
Sellout RefLink benutzen
Aber ganz ehrlich
Bringt mir nichts mehr
Weil die Kampagne ist durch
Also insofern ich verdiene damit noch nicht mal was
Hey Max ich erledige mittlerweile alles auf meinem Laptop unter Linux
Ja gute Sache
Auf meinem Desktop PC
Auf meinem Desktop PC läuft Windows
Und bis jetzt habe ich eigentlich immer auf dem Laptop programmiert
Der PC war nur zum Zocken da
Habe jetzt ein neues Setup
Wie würdest du das machen
Habe vor langem mal gesehen
Dass du immer in einer 4M programmierst
Kannst du das noch immer empfehlen
Ja
Also ich finde das ist die beste Kombination
Ich habe immer eine 4M auf dem zweiten Bildschirm auf
Mit einer Arch-Dienungsinstallation
Natürlich Arch was sonst
By the way
Mit einer Arch-Dienungsinstallation
Das gleiche Setup hatte ich übrigens auch so
Auf meinem Arbeitslaptop
Also nicht auf dem aktuellen
Weil da muss ich ja Windows benutzen
Meine Dienstleistung auf der ich Root bin
Habe ich hier auf
Auf dem zweiten Bildschirm
Und du kannst die Desktop switchen
Also du kannst beispielsweise
Ctrl-Windows-Taste, Pfeil-Taste links drücken
Dann bist du wieder in Windows
Oder Ctrl-Windows-Pfeil-Taste rechts
Dann bist du wieder auf dem anderen Desktop
Dann musst du halt einmal reinklicken
Das ist für mich die optimale Mischung
Aus übrigens hier guten Youtube-Videos
Die ihr da guckt
PepoHappy
Übrigens ich weiß nicht ob ihr den Stream-Titel heute erkannt habt Leute
Das ist nicht PepoHappy
Sondern wider PepoHappy
Es ist wider PepoHappy
Und wer mal geguckt hat
Der wird feststellen
Ich habe sogar ein Emote drinnen
Für wider PepoHappy
Das habe ich nur drinnen
Weil ich vorhin überlegt habe
Sag mal
Es gibt wide PepoHappy
Warum gibt es nicht wider PepoHappy
Und dann habe ich mal gegoogelt
Und habe festgestellt ach ok gibt schon 1000 Emotes
Was ich nicht gefunden habe ist widest PepoHappy
anscheinend. Es geht nicht auf Spielen unter Linux, er will Spielen unter Windows
und aber seine, sagen wir mal, liebgewordene Linux-Umgebung zum Arbeiten
verwenden auf dem gleichen PC. Und ja, da kann ich es nur empfehlen, beste
Kombination, VM und Nudeln mit Lachs. Beste Kombination, VM auf
zweitem Desktop und Windows für alles andere, ja. Also hier machst du alles was
Programmieren, Technik, Netzwerk, was auch immer ist. Wenn es um Spielen geht, Streamen,
Videos bearbeiten oder sonstige Multimedia-Geschichten, wo du unter Linux
keinen Bock drauf hast, machst es unter Windows. Ja, kann ich empfehlen, finde ich,
ist für mich persönlich das beste Setup überhaupt.
Ja, das habe ich mich auch gefragt. War das aus irgendeinem Video von uns früher?
Von irgendeinem Zuschauer-Comment-Video? Ich kann mich... Leute, ich mache YouTube-Videos
seit 13 Jahren. Ich kann mich nicht an jede Aussage und an jeden Spruch in
jedem Video erinnern. Außerdem bin ich 38, da fällt es einem eh immer schwieriger, sich zu
erinnern. Hallo, von 1 bis 10, wie agil bist du, Max?
Also, ich bevorzuge mittlerweile das Wort skalieren und dabei kann ich immer
erwähnen, ich skaliere weder horizontal noch vertikal, sondern ich skaliere nur
noch diagonal. Also ich bin diagonal agil, ich mache
horizontal und vertikal gleichzeitig. Das ist noch besser als agil zu sein.
Das ist quasi das richtige High-Performer-Mindset, um jetzt mal
möglichst viel Bullshit in einen Satz zu packen.
Keine Fulltext-Suche für YouTube-Videos? Ja, cringe. Falsches Video. Gab es hier noch
irgendeine Frage, die ich beantworten wollte, die ich übersehen habe jetzt? Hier lernt man
noch was, ja. Vor allem, wenn man Prime subscribt, habe ich gehört, geht der IQ
durch die Decke. Nicht nur von dir, sondern das ist ja
prozentual für jeden im Chat. Ich habe es gestern schon gesagt, wir haben den
intelligentesten Twitch-Chat, aber das verfällt mit der Zeit. Also da muss man
schon dafür sorgen, dass das vorne bleibt. Shepard95, der macht das richtig.
Ja, siehste, hat er von 95 IQ gleich abgecratet auf 195. Danke für den Sub, Pog.
Welche VM ich benutze? Vmware Workstation. Er auch, ja, beste. 60 Gigabyte RAM sind aber
wahrscheinlich zu wenig. Nein, nein, nein, nein. 60 Gigabyte RAM ist vollkommen
ausreichend. Ich meine, was hatte mein alter Rechner? 32G? Aber gekauft habe ich
ja auch. Das reicht, das ist kein Problem. Guck mal, ich meine ernsthaft. Ich habe so
unsinnig viel RAM und es sind gerade mal 20 Gigabyte belegt zurzeit. Und 20
Gigabyte auch nur, weil es alles sehr, sehr großzügig prefetched und sowas
wird. Und ich habe ja auch meine VM laufen ohne Probleme, mein Windows laufen
ohne Probleme, bin mit zwei Accounts in Windows eingeloggt, habe massig Tabs
offen. Ich meine, das braucht ja auch alles ein
bisschen RAM. Und habe die VM, das ist 60 Gigabyte, das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Ich meine, ich habe der VM 24 Gigabyte RAM gegeben, maximal. Würde ich jetzt vielleicht nicht
unbedingt machen, wenn ich nur 16 Gigabyte RAM im System hätte. Aber du kannst auch eine VM
komplett ohne Probleme betreiben mit 8 Gigabyte RAM oder sogar noch ein
bisschen weniger. Also 60 Gigabyte reichen voll und ganz aus. Mit 60 Gigabyte RAM
kannst du sogar 10 VMs laufen lassen, wenn nicht jede massig RAM Ressourcen
hat und die dann auch allogiert. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Musst dir keine Gedanken machen, 60 Gigabyte RAM ist vollkommen ausreichend.
Machst du eigentlich noch viel mit deinem 3D-Drucker? Naja, ich habe noch nie viel
mit meinem 3D-Drucker gemacht. Aber ich benutze meinen 3D-Drucker
regelmäßig, auch wenn ich gerade aus dem Kopf nicht weiß, was das letzte war.
Doch, doch, noch gar nicht so lange her. Ich habe für die Katze was 3D gedruckt
und zwar, es gibt zum 3D-Drucken Aufsätze für den Wasserhahn. Die kann man so an
den Wasserhahn dranschieben. Dann läuft das Wasser über den
Aufsatz runter so an der Seite lang. Also da hat man quasi am Wasserhahn so ein
kleines Trinkding und nachdem meine Katze unglaublich drauf steht, Wasser aus dem
laufenden Wasserhahn zu trinken, obwohl die drei Katzenbrunnen im Haus
hier verteilt hat, habe ich da so ein Ding mal ausgedruckt und dran gemacht.
Aber das mag sie nicht. Das mag sie nicht. Die will lieber den Kopf
verbiegen müssen, um an den Wasserhahn zu kommen. Kann ich mich trauen, das aufzumachen?
Wieso hast du 100 YouTube? Weil ich zu viel RAM hab. Das muss doch irgendwie...
Freies RAM ist verschenktes RAM. Okay, nice, ich hab's geschafft. Irgendwas, irgendwas...
Komisch mit der P... Irgendwas habe ich übersehen, glaube ich, im Chat. Aber gut,
ich sehe auch nicht alles. Also wenn ich irgendwas übersehen haben sollte an Fragen
und sagen, schreibt es einfach noch mal rein. Okay, also, Fireship-Video wollte ich mir
angucken. Genau, Svelte-Kit in 100 Sekunden. Svelte-Kit zu erklären, wobei, ich muss es nicht
erklären. Deswegen gucken wir uns ja ein Fireship-Video an. Der erklärt es ja. Aber
haben wir hier im Stream auch schon benutzt und ich persönlich, für mich ist
es das angenehmste, so Full-Stack- oder Front-End-Framework.
Das Video ist vorhin erst rausgekommen, ja?
Leute, ich muss jetzt mal was sagen. Jetzt, wo ich das hier gerade sehe mit Rich Harris
und Svelte-Kit. Es greift mittlerweile, so dieses rumgeflame ohne Plan zu haben,
wie man das so Social-Media-technisch sieht, greift schon eine ganze Weile auch so auf
IT-Communities über. Und das hat man beim letzten Svelte-Kit-Release gesehen.
Die haben nämlich TypeScript rausgeschmissen. Zumindest haben das die Leute so verbreitet,
das stimmt nämlich gar nicht. Das Einzige, was sie gemacht haben, ist, sie arbeiten intern in
ihrem Framework, also quasi bei der Entwicklung von Svelte-Kit und Svelte, nicht mehr direkt mit
TypeScript. Aber sie unterstützen TypeScript komplett und empfehlen, glaube ich, sogar TypeScript
als Sprache für Projekte. Nur intern ging ihnen das auf den Sack, weil ihre Compiler-Magic immer
extra Würste für TypeScript gebraucht hat. Das heißt, die Leute haben daraus gemacht,
Svelte-Kit schafft TypeScript ab und haben sich wahnsinnig aufgeregt. Dabei war das nie Thema.
Es sollte nie TypeScript abgeschafft werden in Svelte-Kit und es geht heute immer noch.
Was heißt immer noch? Das ist sogar der empfohlene Weg, das zu machen. Manchmal
weiß ich auch nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist. Gerade IT-technisch würde ich erwarten,
dass die Leute ein bisschen mehr zurückhalten und durchlesen, was an der Sache eigentlich dran ist.
Und dann zu dem Schluss kommen, es ist ja eigentlich Blödsinn, aber es wird gleich voll
ins Horn geblasen. Svelte-Kit schafft TypeScript ab, was überhaupt nicht der Fall ist. Richtig
Chatting-Modus aktiviert.
Ja, und es ist ein ziemlich gutes, reines Frontend-Framework auch. Man kann Full-Stack-Sachen
mitmachen, aber man kann es auch als reines Frontend-Framework verwenden, was ich persönlich
auch sehr angenehm finde.
So the browser can receive fully rendered HTML, which can be critical for performance and SEO.
Then JavaScript takes over to render all future pages like a fast and smooth single-page application.
It provides a built-in router, where every page component represents the UI for a unique URL.
Workstation is free. Nee, es könnte sein, dass Workstation 30 Tage Demo hat. Weiß ich gar nicht.
Nee, aber du findest Keys für vor allem Workstation bei vielen Key-Shops sehr günstig, für ein paar Euro.
Component, though, can have a corresponding JavaScript file to handle data fetching.
This file exports a load function and the return value is made available on the component while
providing automatic end-to-end type safety. In addition, the data is made available on a Svelte
Store, which can be accessed from any component. Svelte Stores sind eine coole Sache, dass das
direkt eingebaut ist. And eliminates the need for complex state management architectures. Pages
Ja, vor allem bei Workstation. Player ist was anderes als vor allem bei Workstation.
Also handle server-side actions like form submissions to update the current page with
zero client-side JavaScript. Forms can then be progressively enhanced to improve the front-end
user experience with JavaScript. In addition to pages, layouts can be used to share UI across
multiple child routes. And they can even fetch their own data. And finally, we have server files
Ja, das ist tatsächlich das, was ich persönlich von Svelte am wenigsten benutze,
die server-side Sache. Aber ich verstehe den Reiz des Ganzen, ja. Und gerade wenn man es wirklich
full-stack machen will und dann auch server-seitig die Seiten vorrendern möchte und sowas in der
Richtung, dann ist es natürlich schon sehr nice. Export functions like get, post, patch and delete
to build RESTful APIs. To get started, create a new project with the CLI. You'll notice it
uses Vite as the build tool. Then we can create our first page by going to the routes directory.
Right-click and the tooling will help you easily create the required file. I'm wrapping this URL
in brackets to make it a dynamic route. That will give us a username parameter we can access
throughout the application. Notice how the component has a prop of data using the page
data interface. This interface is automatically generated based on how we load data from the
server. Wo man es wieder sieht, dass SvelteKit überhaupt kein Problem mit TypeScript hat.
directory and instead of using techniques like prop drilling we can easily access it on the page
data store the code we just wrote is universal meaning it can run on both the client and the
server however you can tell the framework to only run code on the server using the server extension
in a server file you can access things like databases and environment variables that you
wouldn't want exposed client-side and define actions which are functions that run on the
server that can be tied directly to form submissions in the front-end code you can
mix and match different rendering strategies like SSR, ISR and pre-rendering to deploy to
any major platform. This has been SvelteKit in 100 seconds. Check out my new full SvelteKit course
if you want to build a full project with it. Thanks for watching and I will see you in the next one.
Jetzt wissen wir sofort Bescheid Leute. Erstes SvelteKit Projekt direkt am Start. Wobei wir
haben schon ein paar SvelteKit Projekte im Stream gemacht. Ich habe mal eine Frage an euch. Falls
der ein oder andere tatsächlich das Video jetzt verfolgt hat, weil die Videos von Firechip gehen
ja immer relativ schnell, hat sich jemand gefragt warum es eigentlich bei einem Front-End Framework
hier in diesem Video um Server-Seite geht? Oder ist euch das allen klar? Weil ansonsten würde ich
da noch mal ein paar Takte zu sagen warum das überhaupt so eine coole Geschichte ist. Okay
der Chat ist feilfertig. Stimmt, wir hatten heute schon genug Subscriptions, dann ist
obviously alles klar. Okay, next. Dann kann ich das nächste Video machen. Oder was? Was guckt man
als nächstes? Ein gefundenes Fressen für Cloud-Gegner. Microsoft gehackt. Okay, also also ich gehe
irgendwie davon aus, dass das Video Cheatbait ist, weil wenn Azure wirklich großartig gehackt wäre,
das hätte größere Runden gemacht und ich hätte es auf jeden Fall mitgekriegt. Aber mal gucken.
Klingt nach 100%ig Cheatbait oder Übertreibung. Ja, wir hören uns mal den Anfang an, ob es Cheatbait
oder Übertreibung ist. Jeder Service hat andauernd Security-Probleme. Es gibt nichts an großen
Services, was nicht irgendeine wiegeartigen auch immer Security-Probleme hat. Aber wichtig ist doch
zu gucken, was sind das für Probleme, wie viele Leute das betrifft und wie tief gehen die Probleme
oder welche Auswirkungen hat das? Das ist doch das eigentlich Entscheidende. Zum Beispiel, es
könnte auch ein Security-Problem sein, wenn du einen Button angezeigt bekommst, den eigentlich
nur ein Admin angezeigt bekommen sollte. Aber wenn du dann draufklickst, hast du keine Rechte. Also
ja, das ist irgendwie vielleicht sich zurechtgesponnen auch ein Security-Problem. Aber
eigentlich ist es ein Bug, der relativ wenig Security-Implications hat. Was heißt Azure?
Nicht Endrat, nö. Azure heißt Azure. Das ist der Cloud-Service von Microsoft beziehungsweise
der sogenannte, um mal ein paar Buzzwords unter die Leute zu bringen, der sogenannte Hyperscaler von
Microsoft. Weil für manche Leute ist Cloud-Anbieter zu sagen oder Cloud-Provider nicht mal cool
genug. Das nennt man heutzutage Hyperscaler. Also wenn ihr mal irgendjemanden mit Buzzwords um
sich schmeißen hört und da sagt einer der Hyperscaler, der meint damit den Cloud-Anbieter
beziehungsweise den Cloud-Provider. Sorry, haben wir nicht subscribed? Du musst nicht
subscriben. Ich wollte es bloß wissen. Also ja, ich kann das mit Svelte noch mal ganz kurz erklären,
was das coole ist. Also Svelte ist das Frontend-Framework und SvelteKit ist ein
Full-Stack-Framework für SvelteKit. Herr Schocker, danke schön für den Sub. So,
was damit gemeint ist oder die... Patrick hat einen Sub gegiftet. POG-Subscription, nice. Eiko,
jetzt hat er auch einen Sub. Danke Patrick für das Giften und jetzt kannst du so ganz offiziell
fragen. Aber ihr könnt natürlich auch immer Fragen stellen, auch ohne dass ihr Subscriber seid.
Genau, also das ist das Full-Stack-Framework zu Svelte. Mittlerweile ist es sogar so,
dass eigentlich hauptsächlich empfohlen wird direkt SvelteKit zu benutzen. So,
der hauptsächliche, ich sag jetzt mal für mich, Anwendungszweck für sowas wie SvelteKit ist,
dass ich die Kombination benutzen kann aus den Vorteilen von Server-Side-Rendering und
dynamischen Client-Side-Applications. Traditionell war das so, Webseiten werden
auf dem Server gerendert und werden dann an den Client geschickt. Also mit Webseiten werden auf
dem Server gerendert ist gemeint, die Webseite liefert das HTML aus, was der Browser dann
rendert. Das ist ganz klassisch. Ihr geht auf eine Webseite, ihr bekommt ein HTML vom Server
geschickt und euer Browser rendert das HTML. Das ist das, wie das Internet von Anfang an
funktioniert. Eine Sache, HiIQ-Frage, Chat, was ist so eines der Nachteile von reinen Server-Side
gerenderten Seiten? Oder was waren so ein bisschen die Probleme, warum auch andere Möglichkeiten
evaluiert wurden bzw. warum gibt es jetzt so tausend verschiedene Frontend-Frameworks? Also
sprich, was war das größte Problem bei reinen Server-Side gerenderten Seiten? Na ja, zu statisch,
Latenz. Ja genau, das trifft es ganz gut. Also es gab aus meiner Sicht, wie gesagt,
ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Frontend-Entwickler, ich erzähle euch das jetzt einfach mal trotzdem,
gibt es vielleicht noch mehr Sachen, an die ich jetzt so spontan nicht denke. Also das erste
Problem ist bei sehr dynamischen Webseiten, dass du dann das erst mal ohne weiteres kleinen
Javascript gar nicht richtig abbilden konntest. Rein statisch gerenderte Seiten auf dem Server
aktualisieren sich nicht, nachdem du sie bekommen hast. Dafür gab es dann Javascript und das wurde
immer weiter ausgebaut, bis man irgendwann festgestellt hat, okay, man hat mittlerweile
so spezifische Anforderungen an Webseiten, dass es eigentlich nur noch aus ganz viel Javascript-Code
besteht, die im Browser ausgeführt werden und eigentlich das Rendern auf dem Server relativ
unsinnig ist. So, dann kam man halt zu immer mehr Frontend-Frameworks und Client-Side-Applications.
Ich meine zum Beispiel, überlegt euch mal, sowas wie DrawIO, das ist reines Client-Side-Javascript
mit ein bisschen zum Speichern und sowas Backend auf dem Server, das ist reines Javascript hier.
Sowas kannst du nicht machen mit rein Server-Side-gerendertem Content, das funktioniert
nicht. Alter, was ist mit der Musik los? Als würde ich jetzt hier super epische Weisheiten verbreiten.
Sowas kannst du nicht machen. Also dynamische Updates bzw. Anwendungen, die im Browser so
komplex geworden sind, dass sie schon fast Funktionalität von echten Native-Anwendungen
haben, das konntest du nicht mal Server-seitig abfackeln. Das konntest du nicht mal Server-seitig
abfackeln und was wollte ich jetzt am Anfang noch sagen? Ja, und ein weiterer Punkt ist
Offline-Fähigkeit von Seiten. Es gab ja immer mal Seiten, die fast schon wie eine App funktioniert
haben, die quasi auch offline weiterlaufen sollten. Also DrawIO funktioniert beispielsweise auch
weiter, wenn ich meine Internet-Verbindung kappe. Das ist der nächste Punkt, den mit rein
Server-seitig-gerendertem Content nicht machen konnte. Und ein weiterer Punkt ist, dass manche
Sachen auch einfach zu, ich nenne es mal, zu laggy sind. Also wenn du Seiten hast, die sich schnell
updaten, wo sich vieles updatet, wo dynamisch viel passiert, dann müsstest du ja für jedes Update
oder für alles mögliche, müsstest du ja komplett neue HTML-Seiten pullen oder neue Elemente pullen,
Server-seitig die dann irgendwie replacen auf der Seite. Das ist nicht nur eklig, das ist auch nicht
sonderlich performant. So, und irgendwann sind dann die Leute auf die Idee gekommen, warum bauen wir
denn diese ganze klein-seitige Geschichte nicht weiter aus. Leute haben jahrelang mit jQuery
rumgewurstet, da gab es ganz viele Versuche. Das hat dann irgendwann angefangen mit Backbone.js
und Knockout.js und falls diesen Crampel noch irgendjemand kennt. Das ging dann immer weiter
und irgendwann kam dann React. Mit React hat quasi so auch der letzte, so der Riesenboom
von Klein-Seit-Applications angefangen. Also Klein-Seit oder Frontend, das ist immer gemeint,
das ist eine Anwendung, die wird halt vom Server ausgeliefert initial, aber läuft dann quasi zu 99
Prozent im Browser. Hat auch den Vorteil, Klein-Seit-Anwendungen skalieren eigentlich
ganz gut, weil Klein-Seit-Anwendungen erzeugen halt keine Last auf dem Server. Also wenn ich
jetzt, wenn jetzt 30.000 Leute in Draw.io rummalen, erzeugt das keine Last auf dem Server, sondern nur
im Browser des jeweiligen Anwenders. Ja genau, Angular kam dann auch noch, aber React hat so
diesen Riesenboom auch dann wieder mit ausgelöst. So, da gab es noch verschiedene weitere Frameworks,
da gab es dann irgendwann noch Vue.js und dann irgendwie 50 neue Versionen von Angular,
wo keiner mehr genau durchblickt und das mittlerweile genauso bloated ist wie Java.
Und irgendwann kam Svelte. Svelte ist das letzte der, ich sag mal, großen Frontend-Frameworks. Die
drei großen sind eindeutig React auf dem ersten Platz, ganz ohne Frage. React ist der King,
was Frontend-Frameworks angeht. Auf dem zweiten Platz kann man sich jetzt streiten,
im Enterprise-Business wahrscheinlich Angular. Ansonsten overall vielleicht sogar Vue.js,
bin ich mir nicht sicher. Und auf dem vierten Platz ist auf jeden Fall Svelte.js mittlerweile,
zumindest vom Hype-Faktor. So, das sind so die vier großen Frameworks. Es gibt immer noch so
ein paar kleine andere Sachen. So, und jetzt ist das Ding, serverseitig gerenderte Anwendungen
haben aber nicht nur Nachteile gehabt, sondern rein serverseitig gerenderte Webseiten hatten
auch einige Vorteile. Es gibt zwei große Vorteile für mich bei serverseitig gerenderten
Anwendungen. Wie gesagt, mit serverseitig gerendert meine ich nicht die Seite komplett,
sondern der Server liefert HTML, fertiges HTML an den Browser und der Browser rendert das. Es
gibt zwei Vorteile für mich. Ich mache nochmal eine Frage an den Chat. Was sind für euch die,
also eins, zwei große Vorteile von serverseitig gerenderten Websites? Ja, richtig. Ja, beides.
Ihr habt beide recht. Ihr habt alle recht. Das ist der High-IQ-Chat. Sieht man mal wieder. Die
Subscription haben sich einfach schon wieder ausgezahlt. Ich sag doch, most IQ Twitch-Chat
ever. Genauso ist es. Das erste ist, für Suchmaschinen ist das natürlich kacke,
wenn du nur zwei Zeilen Javascript siehst und keinen Seitenkontext, keinen Seiteninhalt. Da
kann eine Suchmaschine nichts mit anfangen. Eine Suchmaschine kann aber wunderbar vom Server
gelieferten HTML parsen und indizieren. Also, wenn du eine Seite haben willst,
die in der Suchmaschine gut gerankt ist, dann war es eigentlich tabu, eine reine
Kleinzeit Javascript-Anwendung zu machen. Konntest du vergessen. Hat nicht funktioniert.
Und das nächste, und das ist ein Thema, was die letzten Jahre immer wichtiger geworden ist,
ist, nennen wir es mal, das was Readme schreibt, Latenz, beziehungsweise das,
was Glitch stattgeschrieben hat, Initial Loading Times. Und zwar eine Seite, die vom
Server komplett als HTML ausgeliefert wird. Nehmen wir mal Google oder so. Die ist einfach,
ja okay. Ihr seht es, Google ist instant da. Instant. Es gibt keine Verzögerung. Google
ist einfach sofort da. Und das geht, weil nichts mehr Javascript-seitig-client-mäßig passieren
muss. Es macht ein Get-Request an den Server, zurückkommt HTML, der Browser rendert das. Die
Seite ist innerhalb von, keine Ahnung, 20 Millisekunden ist die da. Und das ist einfach
fast as fuck. Das nennt man Initial Loading Time. Die ist bei reinen Kleinzeit-Anwendungen ein
bisschen langsamer, weil dort muss erstmal massig Javascript runtergeladen werden. Und das HTML,
was letztendlich der Browser dann rendert zum Anzeigen, wird erst durch Javascript auf dem
Client erzeugt und dann gerendert vom Browser. Dementsprechend ist das langsamer. Initial
Loading Time, Initial Loading Time. Ihr seht es ja, guckt doch mal. Bis DrawIO geladen ist,
ihr seht es, das dauert eine ganze Weile. Google, bam. Das ist halt ein riesen Javascript-Ding,
was erstmal rübergeschoben werden muss. Und die Webseitenbetreiber haben gemerkt,
dass Ladezeiten eines der Hauptgründe sind, warum Leute die Webseite nicht benutzen. Oder
eines der Hauptgründe sind, warum Bestellprozesse aussteigen oder irgendwas. Ladezeiten,
Initiale Ladezeiten sind enorm wichtig. So. Und jetzt sind sie auf die Idee gekommen und das ist
das, wo SvelteKit so... SvelteKit ist übrigens nicht das einzige Framework in der Richtung. Es
gibt noch Next und Nuxt und Konsorten, wo ich mir immer nicht merken kann, für welches Framework
jetzt was ist. Gibt es jede Menge, aber SvelteKit ist eines dieser Frameworks. Und da sind sie auf
die Idee gekommen, okay, warum sollte man da nicht Server-Side-Rendering und Client-Side-Rendering
verbinden? So. Und dann kamen solche Full-Stack-Frameworks auf. Und das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Die Webseite wird initial Server-Side gerendert, inklusive einem ersten State für das ganze
JavaScript. Dann wird das komplett eingefroren. Es wird an den Client ausgeliefert. Der Client
rendert die Seite initial, das HTML, was er kriegt. Und dann nimmt der Client quasi das
JavaScript an der Stelle wieder auf, wo das Server aufgehört hat. Um es jetzt mal so ganz grob zu
umschreiben. Also sprich, du bekommst auf der einen Seite die Möglichkeit, Seiten dynamisch,
interaktiv, Client-Seitig, ja, griffig zu gestalten, wie du es bei Single-Page-Applications
oder Client-Side-Anwendungen gehabt hast. Plus du kriegst den Vorteil von schnellen
Seite-Ladezeiten und Suchmaschinen-Optimierung von Server-Side-Rendering. Deswegen sind solche
Full-Stack-Frameworks so beliebt. Und das funktioniert genauso, wie ich euch das jetzt
so abstrakt erklärt habe. Den Prozess nennt man übrigens Hydration. Also falls ihr im Frontend-Umfeld
mal irgendwas von Hydration hört, dann ist das genau damit gemeint. Der Server rendert initial
die Seite einmal, inklusive initialem JavaScript-Gedöns, friert diesen JavaScript-State ein,
der hydratet den quasi. Dann schickt er das an den Client, Client rendert das, dehydratet den
JavaScript-State und macht dann an der Stelle weiter. So funktioniert das. So, jetzt habe ich
es aber ausführlich erklärt. Wie ist die Seite, auf der alle möglichen Top-Ten-Technologien und
Sprachen aufgezeigt werden? Äh? Azure Directory wird umbenannt. Okay, sollen sie mal machen.
Ja, Schocker, danke für den Sub, aber ich glaube, habe ich schon vorgelesen. Aber kann
man nicht oft genug sagen. Azure AD ist bekommen in Microsoft Entra. Ja, Microsoft unnamen. Ich
erinnere nur mal an Kinect. So ein dummer Zungenbrecher-Name. Ursprünglich hieß Kinect Projekt
Natal, was ziemlich guter Name war, fand ich. Ich sage nur One Xbox X oder .NET, .NET Framework, .NET Core.
Also Microsoft und Benamung. Warum benennen die das um? Mit Active Directory kann doch jeder was
anfangen, Alter. Ich finde es auch so dumm, dass sie Office umbenennen. Jeder kann mit Office was
anfangen. Was kann man mit Informatik Master mehr machen, als was ein Fachinformatiker? Also an Jobs,
so initial. Erstmal nix, kommt drauf an, was du kannst, ja. Du kannst im Durchschnitt, also du
hast im Durchschnitt, da gibt es bestimmt auch aktuelle Statistiken, die das belegen, aber keinen
Bock rauszusuchen, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es so ist. Du verdienst im Durchschnitt
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr, was aber nichts für dich individuell jetzt zwangsläufig bedeuten
mag. Das kann auch wahrscheinlich durch irgendwelche Behördenjobs oder sonst was liegen. Letztendlich
musst du was können und das musst du in beiden Fällen. Du kannst alle IT-Jobs prinzipiell auch
erstmal als beides machen, es sei denn bei irgendwelchen Ämtern und sonst was, die da
formale Voraussetzungen für den Job haben oder nicht. Also was du als studierter Informatiker
besser kannst, sind irgendwelche theoretischen Hintergründe. Du kannst zum Beispiel irgendwelche
Algorithmen, Laufzeit, Abschätzung mathematisch beweisen oder mathematisch untermauern und solche
Geschichten. Das kann ein Fachinformatiker nicht. Dafür hat ein Fachinformatiker nach seinen drei
Jahren Ausbildung deutlich mehr Plan von dem, wie es in der IT-Business-Enterprise-Welt so abläuft,
als jemand, der direkt aus dem Studium kommt. Und zwar in der Form, dass der tatsächlich schon
anfangen kann, was zu schaffen, wohingegen viele aus dem Studium erstmal komplett überfahren sind,
so wie es in der Business-Enterprise-Welt zugeht. Also es sind unterschiedliche paar Sachen. Du
hast recht, es sind nicht genug offene Tabs. So, jetzt sind es genug. Das war der letzte,
der gefehlt hat. Also ich bin mir sicher, mit dem haben wir jetzt genug offene Tabs.
Jetzt completed. Das stimmt. Ja, das stimmt. Also für irgendwelche, ähm, ich weiß nicht,
wie das Glas so für Sehbehinderte so blindenschriftmäßig und Text-to-Speech und solche
Geschichten ist das viel besser, wenn das statisch ist. Aber dann noch ordentliches HTML, statisch
gerendertes HTML ist. Aber was du ganz gut hinbekommst mittlerweile mit Full-Stack-Content
oder mit Full-Stack-Frameworks. Ich habe gerade was getrunken. Es kommt ja auch ein bisschen darauf
an, wo man ist, welche Branche und sowas. Aber im Durchschnitt kann man sagen, man verdient,
als wenn man studiert hat, im Durchschnitt sicherlich noch ein bisschen mehr. Aber wie
du hier siehst, es hat nicht unbedingt für dich individuell was zu sagen. Ja klar, also das war
ich meine. Also sprich, wenn die irgendwelche speziellen Anforderungen haben, dass das nur
für Masterstudenten, dann natürlich, ja. Okay, nice. So, ähm, was, äh, genau. Ich wollte,
ich wollte mich ja jubänen lassen, warum, warum angeblich man die, warum die Cloud gehackt wurde
und, und warum man, warum das gefundenes Fressen für Cloud-Gegner ist. Wie gesagt, ich glaube,
das ist mega jubänt, aber gucken wir uns das mal an. Hä, was? Die Hacks der Woche. Die Hacks
der Woche. Also der hauptsächliche Grund, warum man nicht in die Cloud gehen sollte,
ist erstmal, weil es im Zweifelsfall teuer als Fack werden kann, wenn man nicht weiß,
was man macht. Das ist doch der erste Grund. Weil man vielleicht gar nicht das, das Know-how bei sich
hat, um, um Sachen umzustellen. Aus Datenschutzgründen vielleicht. Gibt, gibt durchaus
einige Gründe, warum man nicht in die Cloud gehen will mit bestimmten Services. Das so pauschal zu
sagen, ist natürlich blöd. Weil es gibt Sachen, die können Cloud-Anbieter einfach besser als
man selbst. Oder höchstwahrscheinlich, ich will ja keinem zu nahe treten, aber ich sag mal,
Kubernetes als Plattform anbieten, kann ein Cloud-Anbieter wahrscheinlich besser als das
selbst zu hosten. Und wer schon mal Kubernetes selbst versucht hat, der wird wissen, der Fehler
liegt im Detail, also das Problem liegt im Detail und sich selbst drum zu kümmern ist richtig großer
Abfuck. Fängt ja schon mal damit an, dass du gar keine Load-Balancer benutzen kannst in Kubernetes,
wenn du es selbst installiert hast. Also nicht out of the box. Bei einem Cloud-Anbieter geht es
out of the box. Also gerade was Kubernetes angeht, sehe ich nicht so. Es ist so unglaublich eklig,
das zu betreiben. Wenn man jetzt nur drei VMs hat, ja, da kann man auch, kann man auch selbst
betreiben. Oder kann man sich auch bei Hetzner oder so holen und dann quasi sich um die VMs
selbst kümmern. Wie auch immer man das will. Es kommt halt ein bisschen darauf an, was wir machen.
Im Kubernetes-Umfeld würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen, nee, das würde ich ganz, das hatten wir auch
schon öfters im Stream, da würde ich ganz stark davon abraten, das selbst zu machen. Es muss nicht
Azure, AWS oder GCP oder so sein. Es kann auch DigitalOcean sein, wenn es ein bisschen günstiger
sein soll. Ja, muss man gucken. Also gucken wir mal. Dean Haunschmied. Hacks der Woche. Bin gespannt.
Herzlich willkommen zu den Hacks der Woche. Es ist das Horror-Szenario eigentlich für alle
Unternehmen, die inzwischen in die Cloud gewechselt sind. Eine Sicherheitslücke,
die in Microsofts Azure AD ausgenutzt wurde. Eine chinesische Hacking-Gruppe hat sozusagen...
Endlich mal einer, der das richtig ausspricht. Die China-Chinesen sind am Start. Die waren's.
...Ugriff auf die E-Mails von 25 Organisationen, größtenteils Regierungsorganisationen,
erhalten. Aber was ist passiert? Spannenderweise... Es gibt kaum Leute, die das selbst können. Und
selbst ein Mann reicht nicht, um ordentliche Kubernetes-Sachen zu betreiben. Da hängt so
viel Zeug dran. Und es erfordert erstens mega viel Ahnung. Und Ahnung von Kubernetes heißt
nicht zwangsläufig Ahnung im Kubernetes-Selbstbetreiben. Ja, das ist tatsächlich so.
Das würde ich auch so sagen. Viele, die sagen, wir müssen das auf Kubernetes machen,
die brauchen wahrscheinlich die Vorteile von Kubernetes gar nicht so sehr. Ja, das ist so.
...wurde diese Lücke nicht von einer... Dummes Werk, danke für den Sub. ...selbst,
sondern von einer US-Behörde entdeckt. Die hat in ihren Logs verdächtige Events des Typen
Mail-Items accessed, nur die Client-App-ID... Ah, hat er Exchange-Probleme oder wie? ...die
war ihnen nicht bekannt. Und nach genauerer Analyse stellt sich heraus, dass das ein
Angriff in mehreren Schritten war. Schritt 1, ein interner, inaktiver Signing-Key wird
entwendet. Das heißt, Microsoft wurde gehackt und hat es nicht kapiert. Mit diesem Signing-Key
war es möglich, Azure-AD-Tokens zu fälschen und die wurden von Azure akzeptiert. Microsoft
nennt das ein Issue Validating the Tokens. Ich nenne es eine Zero-Day-Lücke, aber das sind Details.
Naja, streng genommen ist es ein Issue beim Validieren des Tokens. Hört sich dann aber
nicht so schlimm an. Ich kann jetzt da gar nichts zu sagen, was dahinter steckt. Ich habe bis jetzt
davon noch nichts mitbekommen, aber ganz ehrlich, so großartig ausgenutzt kann das eigentlich gar
nicht geworden sein, weil das hätte doch viel größere Wellen geschlagen und ich hätte da auch
irgendwie was, sei es auf Twitter, auf Hacker-News oder sonst wie, irgendwas zu gesehen. 3. Über die
Get-Access-Token-for-Resource-API kann man diesen Azure-Token gegen einen Outlook-Web-Access-OWA-Token
eintauschen und mit dem kann man dann in die Mailboxen der entsprechenden User sehen. Insgesamt
also eine geleakte Information und zwei Sicherheitslücken. Die Folgen waren insgesamt
gar nicht so schlimm. 25 Organisationen sind betroffen. Und warum? Und warum war das nur so
wenig? Weil ich meine, die Kombination Azure-ID und Exchange wird ja nun wirklich jetzt nicht so
selten eingesetzt. Hat das Microsoft einfach nur schnell genug gemerkt oder sind da noch mehr
Faktoren notwendig, dass das ausnutzbar ist? Bisher unbekannte Akteur hat anscheinend
Spionage zum Ziel gehabt. Da gibt es jetzt einige spannende Sachen zu entpacken. Zuerst einmal das
offensichtliche Argument Cloud oder nicht Cloud. Natürlich vertraut man auf die Cloud und es gibt
eine Sicherheitslücke, dann sind potenziell alle Nutzer und Nutzerinnen dieser Cloud betroffen.
Allerdings ist das meiner Meinung nach kein Argument gegen die Cloud. Denn sind die Hersteller
hier fit genug und Microsoft ist das, können... Mich würde interessieren, warum das nicht bei
mehr Leuten ausgenutzt wurde. Weil wie gesagt Azure-ID und Exchange in Kombi werden sehr viele
Fehler haben, die mit einem Schlag das Ausnutzen dieser Sicherheitslücken für alle Kunden und
Kundinnen unmöglich machen. Das stimmt. Wenn jemand Cloud-Gegner ist und einen entsprechenden
Patch-Prozess hat und die Patches schnell einspielt, dann okay, ist man sicher vor der
Lücke und muss die Daten nicht irgendwo hergeben und geht keine so große Abhängigkeit gegenüber
Cloud-Herstellern ein. Aber was wir immer wieder und immer wieder sehen, zuletzt letzte Woche,
also Patrick, ich verstehe, was du meinst, aber du kannst manche Sachen nicht selbst machen gescheit.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du Datenbanken betreiben willst, irgendwie geo-redundant. Also selbst,
wenn du viel Geld hast, du hast nicht unbedingt in jedem Kontinent, in jeder größeren Stadt
irgendwie ein Rechenzentrum oder sowas. Wenn du geo-redundante Datenbanken betreiben willst,
dass du möglichst schnell vom Anfrageort was ausliefern kannst. Und auch die tausenden
Services, die die da mittlerweile drumherum anbieten. Selbst Unternehmen mit Geld werden
sich sicherlich schwer tun, das in ähnlichem Umfang selbst zu bauen. Ist halt die Frage,
ob man das braucht. Viele machen da sicherlich Dinge, die sie nicht brauchen. Da bin ich schon
deiner Meinung. Aber so allgemein denke ich, kann man das so nicht sagen. Und es ist ja auch nicht
umsonst so, dass sehr viele große Unternehmen, die sich genau um sowas Gedanken machen, sich
trotzdem dafür entscheiden, Services in der Cloud zu hosten. Bei manchen könnte man jetzt noch sagen,
ja okay, das ist, weil sie cool sein wollen. Aber unterm Strich überlegen die sich da schon,
ob sich das preislich lohnt, ob sich das Servicetechnisch lohnt, was man damit machen
kann. Bestimmt die ein oder anderen Schwachsinnentscheidungen dabei, aber im Großen und Ganzen
kommt der Trend sicherlich nicht von ungefähr. Fortinet, teilweise Monate, ja Jahre alte Versionen
noch im Einsatz waren. Dieses Patchen kriegen die Leute einfach nicht hin. Und genau deswegen bin
ich... Ja das liegt aber auch ein bisschen an dem jeweiligen Umfeld oftmals. Warum das mit Patchen
nicht funktioniert. Das sind dann so komische Sachen wie, ja, also produktive Systeme dürfen
prinzipiell nicht angefasst werden. Und wenn ihr, wenn ihr denn sowas braucht, wie Wartungsupdates,
ja dann, dann müsst ihr das dann irgendwie sonntagnachts um drei Uhr machen. Und ja,
neben jemand anderes kann das auch nicht. Also die machen sich oftmal so viele Probleme drumherum
selbst, dass deswegen wird das nicht gepatcht. Wenn man das gleich von Anfang an ordentlich machen
würde, übrigens auch ein Vorteil von der Cloud, wenn man sich mal beispielsweise im Kubernetes
Umfeld das Ganze anguckt, Google übernimmt das Patchen. Und Google schaltet den Cluster auch
aus in der Wartungszeit. Die Cluster, das stimmt nicht. Google schaltet den Cluster nicht aus.
Google schaltet dir im Zweifelsfall Nodes aus für einen Rolling Update in dem Wartungsfenster
Zeitraum, den du angeben musst beim Erstellen von einem Cluster. Oder du lässt ihn leer,
dann macht das Google, wie sie lustig sind. Also viele Abläufe in Unternehmen sind halt
Update-feindlich, was bescheuert ist. Und wenn man die Sachen nämlich gleich ordentlich bauen würde,
nämlich nicht, ja wir stellen da halt mal fünf Linux-Server hin und jetzt dürfen wir sie nicht
mehr anfassen, sondern den Service ordentlich mit einem Loadbalancer davor, im Zweifelsfall
auch mit Automatisierungsmöglichkeiten, dass die Server automatisch aufgebaut sind,
dass man das Update beispielsweise easy automatisch ausrollen kann und sowas. Wenn
das gescheit gemacht ist, ist das mit Updates eigentlich halb so wild. Oftmals wird aber
genau das beim Einführen von neuen Services oder Produkten oder Technologien eben nicht gemacht.
Und dann sitzt man da mit dem Salat, dann hat man was, was von der Architektur eben nicht
dafür gedacht ist, Rolling Updates machen zu können oder sagen wir mal Updates ohne größeren
Impact machen zu können. Und da muss man dann solche Dinge machen wie, oh ja, einmal im Monat,
Sonntag um 3 Uhr darf man die Systeme für eine halbe Stunde abschalten und sowas. Das ist halt
das Problem. Wenn sie auf der einen Seite Anforderungen haben, aber es nicht den Anforderungen
entsprechend aufbauen. Ich bin eigentlich ein Fan der Cloud. Der Impact einer Lücke ist potenziell
riesig, aber das Fixen ist auch zentralisiert. Insgesamt denke ich, ist also der Schaden weit
geringer als bei klassischen Lücken. Und sagen wir mal so, bei manchen Lücken sowas wie, was hatten
wir da? Hard Pleat, Shell Shock und wie hieß das mit dem LDAP und den Java Klassen? Lock for Shell
und solche Geschichten. Ja, da sind vielleicht Sachen in der Cloud auch davon betroffen, aber
man kann davon ausgehen, dass Microsoft und Cloud Anbieter das als eines der allerersten für ihre
Managed Services fixen werden. Aber davon sind ja nicht nur Cloud Anbieter betroffen, sondern alle
anderen auch. Und ich gehe einfach mal davon aus, dass das Patchen bei vielen, die lokal gehostet
oder selbst gehostet Service haben, länger brauchen, als wenn sie was Managedes verwenden
von Microsoft. Ich erinnere mich noch an, war das Hard Pleat, wo du Private Keys potenziell
auslesen konntest von Loadbalancern? Ich glaube schon, das war Hard Pleat. Boah, da war bei uns
die Kacke am Dampfen, Alter. On-Premise-Modellen. Und jetzt zerreißt mich in den Kommentaren.
Zweitens, Intransparenz seitens Microsoft. Sie verwenden in all ihren Blogposts nicht einmal das
Wort Vulnerability, also Schwachstelle und versuchen auch sonst das Ganze so klein wie
möglich zu halten. Wenn man aber bedenkt, dass sie hier nicht kapiert haben, dass so ein Key abhanden
gekommen ist und zwei Sicherheitslücken ausgenutzt wurden, schon eine schiefe Optik. Noch dazu kommt,
dass Microsoft für die Cloud keine CWIs hergibt, also eine gemeinsame Sprache zu finden, zu sagen,
das ist genau diese Lücke anhand einer CWI-ID ist hier auch schwierig. Und der dritte Punkt, Logging,
aber nur gegen Bezahlung. Dieses Mail-Items-Access sieht man nur in den Logs, wenn man eine E5-Lizenz
hat. Organisationen mit einer Microsoft-E3-Lizenz sehen das nicht in ihren Logs. Okay, Lizenzierung
Clams ist ja eh immer PPGa, Oracle ist da der absolute Spitzenreiter, was PPGa lizenziert,
wobei SAP vielleicht noch. Was Lizenzierung angeht, ja, bei Microsoft. Ganz ehrlich,
ich habe jetzt seit dem letzten Job kein Azure mehr verwendet. Ich habe schon vergessen,
wie das heißt. Dieser Log-Explorer in Azure, wie heißt das? Query-Analytics oder irgendwie
sowas. Wie heißt dieser Camper bei Azure nochmal? Also dieses Prometheus, was kein Prometheus ist
von Azure und mit diesem ekligen UI. Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt. Denen ihre Analyse- und
Metrik-Geschichten, die da eingebaut sind. Leute, das ist zwar irgendwie ganz cool, was man damit
machen kann und was man für Queries und Abfragen schreiben und erstellen kann, aber ich finde das
UI und das Handling so abartig. Da ist mir jedes Grafana mit Prometheus lieber. Oder jedes Grafana
lieber. Das UI lädt auch immer ewig. Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt. Azure Query Analytics.
Log-Queries, Azure Monitor. Ja, das Teil hier, genau. Aber da gibt es auch eine Ansicht,
wo man so Grafen und sowas sieht. Ja, aber dieses Teil hier, meine ich, das fand ich immer ziemlich
Payne's Champ. Nicht, dass das, was bei Google in der Google Cloud so viel besser wäre. Das ist
auch Payne's Champ. So und weiter im Text. Okay, das war jetzt alles halb so wild. Okay,
was haben wir als nächstes? Kommentar. Dann die menschlichen Kosten der Ransomware. Wir
reden immer... Also im Prinzip nicht richtig krasser Gebate. Ein bisschen Gebate im Titel,
aber es ist, ich meine, es ist zumindest inhaltlich deckt sich das halbwegs mit dem
Titel. Ich habe jetzt eigentlich mit größerem Gebate gerechnet. Ich dachte,
da kommt jetzt irgendwas ganz abgedrehtes. Oh, guck mal, es gibt einen neuen Opposing Force
Speedrun. Weltrekord Speedrun. Nice. Aber den gucken wir nicht heute an. Ich bin jetzt schon
sidetracked. Das Hijacking alles. Ja, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten. Ich meine, na gut,
Microsoft, Microsoft hat ja wohl irgendwelche privaten Schlüssel zum Signieren verloren. Ob
das jetzt ein Hack ist, ist halt die Frage, auf welche Art und Weise haben sie diese Schlüssel
verloren? Ja, aber wenn jemand das benutzt, um sich Talkends zu sein und daraus dann Talkends
zu erstellen, um auf Exchange zuzugreifen, dann ist das schon Ausnutzen von, kann man sagen,
von Schwachstellen. Das kann man schon als Hack irgendwie bezeichnen. Ja, den Talk wollte ich
ja mit euch auch angucken. Das wird nie was. Das kriege ich heute nicht mehr hin. Kann ich mir
heute alles nicht mehr angucken. Habe nicht genug Zeit für. Chat, gab es bei euch noch
irgendwelche spannenden Sachen, bevor ich mich vom Acker mache? Gab es irgendwelche pepega Sachen,
die passiert sind bei euch, wo wir jetzt nochmal 20 Minuten drüber schwätzen wollen? Wir hatten
ja schon ein paar Sachen. Aber ich kann jetzt nicht mal ein großartiges Video gucken und ich
habe noch 20 Minuten Zeit, bevor Bett getimed. Weil wenn nicht, ich habe heute überhaupt keine
Schmerzen, ein bisschen früher ins Bett zu gehen. Ich bin übelst kaputt. Ja, da hat er aber lange
dran gearbeitet. Ich meine, solche Private Keys sind ganz schön lang. Heute Bewerbungsgespräch
gehabt, massive Zeitverballerung. Echt, warum? 25 Tage Urlaub und den Kram. Naja, ein bisschen
weniger als üblich, okay. Aber wenn die dafür ultra mega krass bezahlen, kann man sich das ja
überlegen. Aber machen sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Meistens ist es ja so, dass Unternehmen,
die bei der einen Sache knauserig sind, auch bei der anderen Sache knauserig sind. Es kommt ja nur
wirklich selten vor, dass es was gibt, wo du sagst, okay, die habe ich echt keinen Bock da zu
arbeiten. Und ansonsten ist auch alles so nervig. Aber die bezahlen so krass. Dann halte ich es mal
drei Jahre durch und alles ist gut. Das kommt vor, aber es ist selten. Also meistens ist es ja die
Unternehmen, die attraktiv sind, sind ja auch aus mehreren Gründen attraktiv. Also vom Geld und eben
den Arbeitsbedingungen. Eine schöne DevOps-Studie. Haben wir das nicht sogar schon geguckt? Das kommt
mir sehr bekannt vor. Ja, ja, das haben wir schon geguckt, das kenne ich. Das haben wir sogar
zusammen geguckt on stream. Benefit, einen Tag pro Woche darfst du auf deren Nacken ins Fitnessstudio.
Das ist alles. Ich meine, wenn das irgendwie so eine Fußnote wäre, so by the way einmal in der Woche,
aber als krassen Benefit zu verkaufen, ich weiß ja nicht. 100% Homeoffice vergisst du es. Damit
haben sie ja anscheinend auch nicht geworben. Also 100% Homeoffice gehe ich ja noch irgendwie mit,
wenn das jemand gar nicht möchte. Damit schließt er natürlich auch aus, dass sich Leute bei ihm
bewerben, die nicht unmittelbar irgendwie so in der Nähe wohnen, wo man gut hinkommt. Aber ganz
ehrlich, Unternehmen ohne ordentliche Homeoffice-Regelung, die wollen heute einfach keine
Mitarbeiter haben, so wie es aussieht. Außer sie sind anderweitig super attraktiv, ja, und sie sind
zufälligerweise, keine Ahnung, Google, Apple, Microsoft. Und selbst da bleiben die Leute im
Durchschnitt ja nicht lange. Hat jemand Erfahrung mit Jobs und Auswandern in der Schweiz? Die Frage
kommt immer mal wieder, aber nee, habe ich nicht. Also ich habe die letzten zwei, also ich habe
letzte und vorletzte Woche am Stück Homeoffice gemacht, weil ich davor mehrere Tage am Stück in
Frankfurt war. Und ich habe es nicht vermisst, nach Frankfurt zu fahren. Gerade weil mich die
Leute im Zug immer so aufregen und generell alles in Frankfurt aufregt. Ich habe das ehrlich gesagt
auch während Corona-Zeiten nicht vermisst, da wo Zwangs-Homeoffice war. Ich war sogar der Meinung,
wir haben noch nie so gut und effektiv zusammengearbeitet wie zu Homeoffice-Zeiten. Aber
gut, in meinem alten Team waren halt auch, sag mal, die meisten Leute, mit denen ich
zusammengearbeitet habe, waren halt so die übelsten Kellerkinder wie ich. Und dementsprechend kannten
die sich super aus, was Teamspeak, Online-Gaming und sowas angeht und wussten auch, wie man
Meetings online hält gescheit. Weil ganz ehrlich, Leute, die beispielsweise MMO-Rating-Erfahrung
haben und wissen, wie man sich in einem 20-, 30-, 40-Mann-Rate ordentlich verhält im Teamspeak,
die können auch online über Teams ordentliche Meetings machen und wissen, wie man seine
Technik im Griff hat und wie man Sachen shared und wie man gescheit redet, ohne das Mikrofon
im Pommes stecken zu haben. Ja, das waren einfach die Besten. Es hat wunderbar funktioniert, weil
wir eben Leute haben, die wissen, wie man online miteinander arbeitet. Auch unabhängig von der
Arbeit wussten die das schon. Und bei uns hat das bei uns, also im alten Thema, das wirklich
astrein in Corona-Zeiten funktioniert. Umso bescheuerter war es ja, dass erst erzählt wurde,
also da, wo ich alter Arbeitgeber, nicht neuer, als erst erzählt wurde, ah Leute, es läuft ja so gut,
wir haben jetzt auch eine tolle Homeoffice-Regelung. Wir machen das dann alles so weiter. Und dann,
als Corona vorbei war, hieß es, ach nee, übrigens, wir haben gesagt, wir machen das so weiter,
aber wir machen das jetzt doch nicht so weiter. Ja, und dann sind halt viele Leute abgehauen. Ich
glaube, es sind über 100 Leute Ende letzten Jahres aus der IT abgehauen dort. Ich war einer
davon. Also gekündigt. Abgehauen bin ich erst am 31.3. Kenne ich aus eigener Erfahrung, ja. Ist so.
Hey, wenn du den passenden Chef hast, geht das. Wenn du da irgendwie den 68-jährigen Boomer sitzen
hast, der Online-Gaming für verrohend und jugendgefährdend hält, dann nicht. Wasseresser,
8 Monate. Prog-Subscription, danke für den Sub. Okay, Leute, dann sehen wir uns morgen. Ich bin
halt echt mega kaputt. Und, okay, ich bin mir noch nicht 100% sicher, ob morgen, aber den
nächsten Stream, den wir uns sehen, machen wir wahrscheinlich wieder ein bisschen Prog-Ausstells,
noch ein bisschen was basteln wieder. Wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn ich fit genug bin. Wenn ich nicht
fit genug bin, dann nicht. Aber ich hab, ich hab da was hier überlegt, was wir machen können.
PostChamp. Offer in Zveld. Frontend brauchen wir dafür eigentlich nicht. Egal, wir bauen für alles
einfach einen Zveld-Frontend, ob man es braucht oder nicht. Kommando-Zeilen-Tool macht zwar keinen
Sinn mit Frontend, aber wir machen ein Minus-Minus-Surf-Option, was den Frontend, was den
Server launcht und das Zveld-Frontend ausliefert. Da kann man zwar dann nichts mit machen, aber man
hat's. Leute, du kommst genau richtig. Relax, du bist genau rechtzeitig am Start. Leute, wir sehen
uns. Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal. See you.